so look no matter where I go right and
everybody wants to know Pat what do you
think about the state interview they did
do you agree with them do you not agree
with them I can't believe you sat down
with them don't you have two daughters
How could somebody with two daughters
sit with a guy like that oh my God it
was awesome my kids go to a Christian
School everybody was like oh your dad is
sitting down we'll take all your data
sitting down would say it's great
co-workers family relatives friends on
Instagram all over the place they're
asking I will tell you what my biggest
takeaway was with sit down with Tate
here's the reality of it I sat here
while we're talking to the guys here in
the room and I asked who would I not
interview Mike my question who would I
not interview that I disagree with or
agree with and we couldn't come up with
a list I'd sit down with Putin I'd sit
down with uh uh Kim from North Korea I'd
sit down with zelinski I'd sit down with
anybody to interview them to ask the
following question why do you believe
what you believe in what makes you do
what you do whether I agree or disagree
with them why here's why
here's a specific message to those of
you that disagree with what Tate
believes in okay if you disagree with
what he believes in why don't you go
talk about it on social media and let's
just see if there's an audience think
about AOC I may not agree with what AOC
agrees in in regards to taxes how to run
companies you know how to run a economy
a country any of that stuff we may not
be on the same side and she may hate
capitalists she may despise capitalists
but guess what she did she went and
presented her argument and now she's got
nearly 15 million people on Twitter that
follow her content because she's got an
argument I'm Armenian this last week was
a rough week for Armenians Azerbaijan
out of nowhere came out and attacked and
a lot of brutal things happened to
Armenia this past week but somebody from
the Turkish Member of Parliament just
tweeted something out in a video he's
given this message and he says the
following and I want to read it to you
and it's disturbing but I want to see
what kind of a reaction you get from
this guy and I want you to say whether
we should ban this man from Twitter or
not but I want you to First hear what
this man had to say here's his message
he says we say to the Armenian
Administration make up your mind I
remind you once again that the Turkish
nation has the power to erase Armenia
from history geography and that they
stand at the limit of our patience let
me say this one more time let me remind
you Armenia what we did to you Turkish
Member of Parliament he's saying this in
a video he posted on Twitter it's not
like somebody leaked it from a private
meeting he's proudly telling the
Armenian people we did The Armenian
Genocide even though we don't like him
when people say that remember what we
did to you we can do it again so you
better be quieter you listen to what we
got to do you're starting to drivers and
saying and we're getting a little bit
impatient about it now 99 of you
watching this you ain't Armenian 99 of
you are like I don't even follow I
couldn't even tell you where Armenia is
I couldn't even tell why John is it
doesn't matter
should this man be banned the answer is
no you know why the reason why he
shouldn't be banned is because it's
important for us to see how people are
wired and then you're able to make a
decision for yourself and say I agree or
disagree or you could say how could a
man A Member of Parliament from Turkey
say something like this and I take this
as a threat you're not a dummy you can
go watch the video I'll put the link
below to my tweet go watch the video for
yourself and make a decision for
yourself but I don't want that guy to be
banned why because I get to talk about
it and say see what he said and then you
get to say I agree with Pat Pat you
don't know what you're talking about I
agree with them no problem we need O.J
Simpson on we we need him on for people
to be be able to watch to see what he
has to say we need these folks to be on
now I'm not trying to compare these guys
to Tate
pate's call out is to how he views how
men are being treated his call out is to
the government his call us to a lot of
different people you don't have to agree
with it all you can do is if you think
you have a better argument go present
your argument but if you think he's got
a good argument also give him a platform
for the world to hear his argument
because God knows if there's anything we
need more of today is debate Newsome the
other day called out DeSantis on Twitter
I love that because we need more debate
just a year ago I put five million
dollars on the table to trying to get
Donald Trump and Obama to sit down for a
three-hour conversation slash debate in
a podcast and we heard back from one
camp we didn't hear back from the other
Camp why because America needs more
debate so when you ask me a question
what was he like that's one on one time
between me and the guest I won't reveal
that to the people because it's between
me and the private time I have with the
individual I'm sitting down with there's
an experience that we will share and we
we had a conversation to get it
fascinating but Enrique regards to why
we were able to host it and why at this
point hundreds of millions of people
have seen the clips on tick tock on
Instagram on Twitter on you know
Facebook on YouTube all over the place
and people get to make a decision for
themselves and by the way if you haven't
watched the entire podcast it's a Five
Hour podcast and millions watch the
entire five-hour podcast if you haven't
watched it yet click over to watch it it
feels like five minutes and if you want
to get directly in contact with Tate
whether you want to agree or disagree
but you want to ask them a question
maybe FaceTime with them for 15 minutes
you can actually buy FaceTime with them
for 15 minutes on a new app called
minute download the app and get in
contact with him and many other
influencers and experts take care
everybody bye-bye
foreign
[Music]